today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
judging from the emails i've been
getting from many of you um
it sounds like much of my audience
agrees with me
that it feels as though american
democracy
is in peril it's a sort of precarious
state right now hanging on the brink
with the president openly saying
the election is rigged that the correct
result would be that
he wins and that if he doesn't win
preemptively he's saying it will have
been fraud
and he will not necessarily leave the
white house peacefully so
it's natural it's common it's logical
to be feeling despair and helplessness
right now donald trump and his cronies
have gotten away with everything with so
much
and our old friend john nichols at the
nation
wrote a really great piece about the
bernie sanders toolkit
for defending against donald trump's
threats to democracy bernie sanders
actually spoke at george washington
university last week
and went through what must happen
and i think this is useful both to
understand the nuts and bolts
but also just to have some hope some
hope so here are the ideas bernie's
plan to defend democracy number one
establish a nonpartisan commission to
oversee the election now the devil
is always in the details with these
nonpartisan commissions
uh but but that is the idea have by far
the largest voter turnout in american
history bernie and i
110 aligned on this i've been saying for
months now
whatever the reality is going to be
about voter suppression
whatever else the biggest ever turnout
is the starting point to trying to
remove donald trump
people should vote as early as possible
says bernie
absolutely the earlier you vote either
through in-person early voting
or vote by mail or hand delivering your
absentee ballot
the earlier the better all state
legislatures
must allow mail-in ballots to be counted
before election day this is key
32 states already allow this some don't
if we can get a jump on counting mail-in
ballots
we reduce the threat of the scenario
in which donald trump is slightly ahead
in some key states on election day
and uses lawyers to stop or slow down
the counting of
as yet uncounted absentee ballots the
more ballots that are counted early the
better off we are
news media should clarify says bernie
there is no longer a single election day
it's important that
media also explain to people you can
vote now in many states
early voting has started in many states
mainland voting has started in many
states and that it is not just about
november 3rd
anymore social media companies must
stop disinformation from being spread on
their platforms
we have a blockbuster story from channel
4
in the uk about donald trump's targeted
deterrence of black voters in 2016
and a big piece of that is social media
and it is also uh
uh on the social media companies to stop
disinformation
and there should be both congressional
in dc and state hearings in state
legislatures
to explain how the election will be
handled
in the event of all of these various
scenarios now not all of these ideas are
bernie's original ideas the nonpartisan
commission for example
was the idea of former director of now
national intelligence
dan coats the aclu has been putting
forth a lot of these ideas etc but the
point is
there are things to do now not waiting
until later
if we wait we lose biden needs an
army of lawyers ready to go now not on
november 4th
we learned last week that at least some
lawyers the dnc
and the the biden campaign have at the
ready those lawyers need to not just be
ostensibly ready the lawyers need to
know
now not later what are the different
strategies that donald trump's lawyers
might
use to swing the election to him the
time is now not later
we're at a structural disadvantage here
if we are playing defense
and they are playing offense they only
need one strategy we haven't thought of
they might have six strategies if we
defend against five they've got number
six so
there is a difficulty implicit in
playing defense in this way
but the time is now to think about it
not uh not later
so get your absentee ballot if that's
your plan you can go to
vote dot org slash absentee hyphen
ballot
very important vote dot org
forward slash absentee hyphen
that's the dash ballot you can also just
google vote.org absentee ballot it'll be
the first link that comes up
and we are linking to that website in
the description to the youtube video
i tracked my ballot yesterday here in
massachusetts
it's currently pending it shows that my
primary ballot was of course received i
voted absentee in the primary
they haven't been sent out yet most
states have tracking systems
vote.org will tell you exactly how to
register in any state in which you live
very very important bernie has a plan
we need plans we need strategy we can't
wait until 11 pm on november 3rd
when the trump lawyers get ready to
petition courts to stop the counting of
absentee ballots
we wait until then we're done uh so
that's why it's so important to move on
this
right now and uh there we can all do
something even if it's just having a
plan that
increases the likelihood of your vote
being tallied correctly that's a plan
that's something we can do
yes you can phone bank yes you can
volunteer to be a poll worker
so on and so forth uh joe biden's wife
jill biden potentially the future first
lady of the united states depending on
what happens in november
is pretty clever and she's also quite
astute when it comes to dealing with
media now certainly she's had media
training i'm guessing it has been ramped
up
given that joe biden is the nominee but
she seems to have a bit of a natural
ability for this i'm going to play a
clip for you today of jill biden
completely shutting down
cnn's jake tapper who tries to bring up
the issue of joe biden's gaffe
and jill biden does something that is
really it's a clinic
on how to be interviewed she says gaffs
trump is president what are you talking
about joe biden's gaffe so i'm gonna
play the clip for you
then we'll discuss it i'm resisting my
instinct
to first tell you all of the interesting
things about this clip
i'm not going to do that let's watch it
first and then we will talk about it
your husband has been known
to make the occasional gaffe oh you
can't even go there you can
after donald trump you cannot even say
the word
i can't even say the word no but are you
not
done it's gone the gaffe issue is over
because
so over so jake tapper doesn't even know
how to respond and what jill biden did
here is super
interesting both from the perspective of
the interviewer
and the perspective of the interviewee
now i've been on both sides of this i've
been the interviewer
asking questions of a guest that the
guest may not want to answer
i've also been a guest being asked
questions
that i either you know it's not
typically that i don't want to answer
them but that i either find boring or
lame or distracting or
improperly framed questions so i've been
on both sides of this
joe biden has handled this perfectly in
that she resisted opening up the can of
worms
she reframed as we talk about it in a
moment you'll see what i mean
and she did it in a charming and
friendly way
without attacking the interviewer and
without making it awkward
but simultaneously reminding the
audience of how absurd it is to talk
about joe biden's gaffes
when the president is donald trump there
are two other ways that she could have
done this
based on the typical media training and
preparation so
one thing that jill biden could have
done and she didn't do it one thing she
could have done is
to do a typical standard reframe and
pivot okay
so that would be something like
acknowledging biden's gaffes
but pivoting to issues which would start
with some kind of mild acknowledgement
it might be
you know what about what about the
gaffes you know my husband he says
what's on his mind he's passionate
and sometimes things come out in a way
that
he would redo if given the chance but
what this election is really about
is the future of this country and
healthcare and coronavirus
so i'm sure if you've watched any
interviews in your life you've heard
people respond that way when interviewed
and the downside of it is it does
feel like not answering the question
because it's not really answering the
question so
she didn't do that the other way jill
biden could have responded
would have been to sort of more
forcefully and noticeably refuse to
answer and that often looks very
bad right so i'm not here to talk about
that or
this is an election about issues not
about gaffes or
no comment right i mean that's really
really bad that's
not good and she didn't do that but what
jill biden does and we're going to watch
it a second time now armed with the
knowledge of how to interpret this
what jill biden does is to essentially
make it a big joke
while being friendly and reminding
people that biden's gaffes
are nothing compared to trump's years of
insults and attacks
attacks and mocking a disabled reporter
using racist and xenophobic terms
suggesting people inject bleach and on
and on and on
and the way you know that this was
effective is that
jake tapper he's just out of ideas
he retreats to just repeating what she
says jake tapper says
oh the issue is over let's look at it
one more time
your husband has been known um
to make the occasional gaffe uh oh you
can't even go there you can
after donald trump you cannot even say
the word
i can't even say the word no but are you
not
done it's gone the gaffe issue is over
because
so over so this might not seem that
notable if you don't look at it more
deeply
but that is actually a very skilled and
tactful way
to handle this question and this issue
and by the way
it's not just optics jill biden is right
sure
joe biden has been gaff-prone over the
years
donald trump gaffs every week of this
presidency
as much as joe biden has in the last
decade and she was able to make that
point
without insulting jake tapper without
attacking the question or the network
it's also quite frankly a bit of a lazy
question let's now
look at it from the interviewer's point
of view if jake tapper wants to prevent
jill biden from being able to do this
he has to come up with something more
specific your husband once said
x and that was deeply offensive to why
why do you think he hasn't apologized is
he unwilling to admit that that was a
mistake
you have to frame the question more
powerfully because if jake tapper does
that
jill biden can't get out of it as easily
and as smoothly as she did
so this is partially that jill biden
handled the question really well and
wasn't going to put up with this
absurd idea that the biden gaffes are
the problem when
you look at the last four years of trump
but also jake tapper brought it up in
sort of a lazy way and it allowed her to
do this but
her identifying it quickly and diffusing
it
in a friendly and cordial way was what
was astute really a clinic on how to
handle interviews
let me know what you think let me know
what you're expecting for tonight's
debate which we will be live
for starting at 8 30 pm eastern time on
youtube twitch and facebook
i'm on twitter at d pacman i look
forward to hearing from you
the david pakman show at david
davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the david pakman show is
mostly funded by
members who sign up at joinpackman.com
it's cheap it's quick it's easy and you
get access to the
world famous award-winning bonus show
okay yeah i mean the rewards we give out
but still awards nonetheless
a grab a membership at joinpakman.com
today
our primary source of revenue it is
really not a good week for donald trump
the uk's channel 4
has released a bombshell investigation
exposing that in 2016 the trump campaign
actually had a specific strategy to
prevent
black people from voting now remember
that publicly in 2016
trump was sort of paying lip service to
how much he loves black people where is
my african-american he said a couple
times during rallies
saying he's going to do so well with
black voters but privately
they knew that black voters were going
to go overwhelmingly for hillary clinton
and rather than trying to convince
black voters to vote for trump what they
did
was to try to keep black voters from
voting altogether and the channel 4
investigation
really well done exposes exactly how
they did this and there's really a lot
to go through here
this was done through social media
targeting with very detailed analytics
the trump campaign had three and a half
million
black americans in their database of
about 200 million voters
and they categorized those black
americans overwhelmingly under what was
called a deterrence campaign meaning
deter folks from voting that's what the
deterrence category was
people that the campaign hopes do not
vote so for example
in georgia despite black voters
const uh black uh black americans
making up 32 percent of the georgia
population they were 61
of the deterrence category in north
carolina black people are 22 percent of
the population
but they were 46 of the deterrence
category
similar numbers in wisconsin and in
other places
there were also hispanic and asian
americans disproportionately
in these deterrence campaigns and
meanwhile
the get out the vote campaigns were
disproportionately
white voters and indeed we can't say it
was
specifically because of this but
certainly it played a role
black turnout fell in 2016
for the first time in 20 years the way
they
worked these campaigns included for
example
using highly produced videos containing
clips of
hillary hillary clinton using the term
super predator
and showing those to the deterrence
group
along with other tactics and again the
idea being dissuade black voters from
voting at all they know that trump's not
going to do well with the black voters
try to get black voters to say i don't
know that i want to go out and vote for
hillary and try to simply keep them home
so there are a few things to discuss
here first of all
it's shocking to see it done so brazenly
but it makes sense that the trump
campaign would try to deter
black people from voting let's just be
very very real here
uh the trump campaign didn't make sense
for black voters or latino voters or
others because their policies were not
going to be good for those groups plain
and simple so
hillary clinton won the black vote 89-8
in 2016
and donald trump's campaign identified
that
if you uh if you uh can keep a group
that is going to skew so heavily in
favor of hillary clinton at home
it's good for you so it's not surprising
from a mathematical perspective if you
were trump's campaign
publicly of course you say yes black
americans vote for trump we're going to
make it great for everybody it's going
to be fantastic
privately you know they're not going to
vote for you and you're better off just
trying to keep them home so
it is a rational strategy given the
numbers and the data
second remember that the social media
platforms are a huge part of this
facebook allowed this to be done and
indeed
channel 4 as part of their investigation
went to facebook and said
you know do you have a comment on this
and facebook said
listen we've changed things since 2016
which
is a way of saying yeah it happened in
2016 and we allowed it to happen
they said we now have 35 000 people
working to ensure
the integrity of our platform we now
have rules
that prohibit campaigns that are trying
to suppress the vote so
they are conceding that this this
happened
and that this took place so the
platforms
that allow this stuff are a big part of
the story in addition to a republican
platform
that is completely unappealing to black
voters and black voters accurately
determine that but then there's a third
part
which is trump's doing this again this
year it's not being done in the exact
same way
but with voter purges in
disproportionately black areas
with fear campaigns with intimidation
tactics talking about you know
democrat-run
urban areas and cities are going to have
police on election day and we're going
to be monitoring and blah blah blah
the goal is the same although the
tactics
are different we can't let them win with
it i predict
very high turnout from black voters this
time around
whether that will lead to a joe biden
electoral victory
well we've got to go out and vote you
know that we have a
very interesting situation right now
where we are seeing
the joining the melding of two major
stories
and one kind of explains the other we
have on the one hand
the questions that have lingered because
donald trump never released his tax
returns
about whether trump is as wealthy as he
claims
whether trump's businesses are as
profitable as he says they are
whether donald trump has problematic
debts to others
and thanks not to donald trump but
thanks to the blockbuster new york times
investigation the answers to all of
those questions
are yes yes and yes and in fact there
are a total of 420 million dollars in
debt that donald trump has
300 million of which are loans that will
come due during donald
trump's second term as president if he
gets one so that's one story
okay talked about that yesterday
secondly
we have this story from july which i've
been on top of for a while
which is that the trump campaign is
accused of
uh of of uh laundering money
through its campaign laundering donor
money
and doing all sorts of sketchy and
potentially illegal things with donor
money
that i told you about in july this is
now coming together
with the added piece of trump's former
campaign manager brad parscale
uh threatening to harm himself and
allegedly hitting his wife and getting
arrested in florida and i'll tell you
how that relates to it
why is donald trump's campaign
laundering money if they are
well it seems weird to do something so
risky just for kicks
it is explained by the taxes if trump
has 300 million in loans coming due soon
and 420 million in total debt and his
businesses aren't doing nearly as well
as he claims
which was also exposed by the recent new
york times tax bombshell
then the reason he's laundering money
could be
to free up money that was donated to him
for his campaign
to pay back some of those debts i mean
it's the crudest
top level analysis the details could
vary
but that would be a very reasonable
inference from what we are seeing
if whoever trump's creditors are and we
still don't know the full scope of who
they are
if they plan to come for trump's money
starting in the next few years
then trump urgently needs to get cash to
pay them and
if we really want to speculate and this
is the brad parscale piece and now we're
going much further
we told you yesterday on the bonus show
that donald trump's former campaign
manager brad parscale
was taken by police to a hospital
because he was threatening to harm
himself he had barricaded himself in his
home he had according to his wife 10
guns with him
his wife reportedly had bruises on her
etc etc
anytime someone is threatening harm to
themselves or others we don't make fun
of that that's serious
but the timing of it is interesting
because based on the reports about money
laundering from july
par scales companies were major players
in laundering the money
and at the exact time that the new york
times story breaks which is the
beginning of the unraveling maybe
of the money laundering and of trump's
taxes brad parscale has a breakdown
are they related well we don't know i
mean it is speculative
we do commentary and opinion here that's
what we do the timing makes me wonder
about it very very much
the question in the end is how much jail
time can you end up with
if you launder millions for a sitting
president if that is indeed what brad
parscale did
it could make even the most stable
person maybe lose their cool we don't
know
we'll see last thing to mention here you
can tell that they have the goods
at the new york times the new york times
story about trump's taxes
likely is completely accurate because
all of the reactions are distractions
some trumpists have been tweeting
you know it's illegal to leak someone's
taxes who
gave it to the new york times that
concedes
that they are really trump's taxes right
or why was this published right before
an election that's dirty they're trying
to influence the election
well that concedes that these are
trump's real
taxes right or who cares if trump didn't
pay taxes that makes him smart well
that concedes that what the new york
times is reporting
is accurate and of course trump has
casually said oh it's all fake it's just
fake news
but 99 of the rebuttals that the right
is running with
aren't substantive they are non-sequitur
what about
ism the next five weeks are going to be
fascinating we will see tonight
in the first presidential debate you've
got to join me live for this thing
we will see tonight at the first
presidential debate uh
whether the topic of donald trump's
taxes comes up we will continue covering
it on our
instagram page davidpakmanshow on
instagram make sure you're following us
there we'll be back right after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today edward watts who is
both professor and chair in the history
department at the university of
california san diego
he is also author of the book mortal
republic how rome
fell into tyranny as well as the
upcoming book rome's eternal decline
and fall available next year from oxford
university press
it's so great to have you on edward
thank you david i'm really excited to be
here
so increasingly i'm hearing things from
my audience about
listen uh all great empires have fallen
in history
sometimes they fall slowly the idea of
the united states
as this permanent empire
is a-historical and you wouldn't even
necessarily know it while it's happening
so
maybe as an analogous situation we can
start with
with rome um talk a little bit about
how did rome fall how long did it take
and how noticeable was it at the time
yeah i mean the interesting thing about
rome is the transition from the republic
to the empire is something that lasts
nearly 100 years and it starts with a
series of problems
mainly connected to wealth inequality
that you see emerging
with the development of a financial
system in the second century bc
and the initial phase in this was
one where people were concerned about
the issue but trusted the system to
resolve it
and after about a generation it became
clear the system was not
effectively resolving this issue and you
started getting political conflict
but it took another century before the
system completely collapsed
and i think what you see in that is the
system continually reset itself over
that time
so that there would be a crisis people
would feel like the crisis passed and
they would assume that that was the end
of it and this long
durable and really successful republican
system had weathered the crisis and
would move on
so at the time if you were uh an
average roman citizen and you recognized
that
maybe your life wasn't that good you saw
inequality much the way that inequality
inequality is noticeable today you would
not necessarily have said
this this is part of the eventual
downfall
i think that that's right i think that
when you're in a successful
political system that's been around for
a very long time the assumption is that
that system
has something natural that that makes it
succeed
and you don't assume that that system is
flawed or that system might be
undergoing changes that could completely
undermine it
and the other thing that's important is
uh in the roman context these crises
would happen maybe once a generation
and so you would live through it and you
would assume that was
that was bad but now things are back to
normal and we can move forward
and it's only with the ability to see
more than a century's sequence of change
that we can say well this is actually a
very long process of degeneration and
decline
but the people living through it didn't
live through that century
and when they did experience these
things they experienced them in real
time and so something that happened 25
years ago
will feel very distant even though as a
historian we look at this and we say
this is part of a century-long process
and i think in the us we can see
something very similar when did this
process of political
degeneration start in the united states
did it start in the 60s did it start in
the 90s
did it start in 2016 but we
continually think these things reset uh
and
the reality is of course we might be
part of a process that started 60 years
ago
and we just haven't noticed that we're
in the middle of something that will
last a long time
this this analogy this idea is used very
often by technologists and futurists
which
which uh you know they point out that
when you are in the middle of rapid
technological change
on a day-to-day basis it really doesn't
feel very fast and because of our
lifespans and the ways in which we
interact with the world
if technology is advancing more quickly
or less quickly it's not
often that noticeable as you're living
through it and it seems that you're
pointing out something similar
i think that that's exactly right we
experience everything
on a human level in a a day is 24 hours
just like it was in the roman period
and so that means that change evolves it
can evolve very rapidly
or it can take a long time and if it's
taking a long time
we aren't always noticing that process
because our attention shifts to
something else
and so i think the technological analogy
is a very good one because
we live with this on a daily basis we
experience it we interact with it
and so the changes are things that we
don't necessarily
recognize as part of a long process that
lasts
decades or even a century when we think
about
the united states now as with 330
million
people one of the most populous
countries
in the world although certainly not not
the most anymore
um is there some historical analogy
in terms of the idea of the country
separating
into smaller countries and this is
something that my audience asks
frequently typically for cultural
reasons in the sense that you know when
you look at the northeast compared to
most of the states in the mountain time
zone there are not only
they're not only very far when you look
at you know a continent the size of
europe these would be many
many countries away culturally there are
significant differences
uh religiously when it comes to
economics
is there any historical analogy we can
look at for the successful
successful being the key piece uh sort
of sort of
a disassembly of a larger country into
component parts or is that something
that historically has not ever gone well
uh the roman empire actually did this um
so in the later fourth century the roman
empire
devolved into a system of kind of
central administration with shared
responsibility so emperors were based in
the west and
based in the east and generally speaking
that worked pretty well in the 4th
century
but in 395 those territories separated
and generally speaking that separation
was something that
people acknowledged had happened but
there was this understanding that the
east and the west were one
imperial system laws issued in the east
were binding on the west
but eventually that stopped and as you
move into the sixth century there's a
roman regime
based in italy that is effectively
separate from the east
and there were conflicts eventually that
developed but
much longer it's a much longer process
and the conflicts developed after almost
a half century of these sort of
interactions being peaceful and more or
less respectful
and so you you can see this but i think
the process in rome was one where
uh the needs of the individual regions
were such
that the central administration couldn't
effectively address all of the problems
across this
vast territory and the roman empire was
bigger than the united states
at that point and so i think that that
would be the example we might look at
is you if you have different regions
with different needs
a central government needs to be able to
fairly address
those challenges and if it can't then
there really is
a need for something that does more
effectively address regional challenges
than a central administration is capable
of doing there are going to be people
who listen to this conversation
and say that even though in terms of the
number of years
in in terms of sort of human history the
last
few hundred years of the united states
uh are are
it's a short period of time that such
significant changes have taken place
technologically uh with regard to sort
of the state of homo sapiens on this
planet that
looking at the fall of rome is simply
not analogous to what we have today that
we have
you know uh government systems that are
more developed with all sorts of
different mechanisms from executive
orders the ability to print
money currency treasury you know just
you the the full list of differences
and that what happened then could not
happen now
in the same way what would you say to
people who would assert that
i would say on some level um that's
correct on another level i think we
underestimate what the romans were able
to do
okay i'm sorry i would say that that's
correct in you know in large part
because
you're exactly right the technological
sophistication the communication
mechanisms
the extent of what government does all
of these things
romans couldn't have even imagined you
know that's an empire that was governed
based on sending messages as fast as
someone could carry them
and so you had a system that was based
on like it taking two weeks for you to
hear what happens in egypt when you're
based in rome
and so that's exactly right that there
are really significant differences
but there's also elements of how
polities come together and how people
develop
expectations of what it means to be part
of a political system
and in that sense rome can help us think
about some of the dynamics that we
experience and we see
and so rome i think offers us a lot of
tools
to think with and to imagine what
possibilities might come
out of the political challenges we face
i mean so i agree with you rome is not
it's not the united states 1.0
but rome does offer us ways to think in
a new manner about what could happen
here
and to imagine possibilities that maybe
our
most recent and maybe even the american
historical experience doesn't allow for
us
simply because this historical
experience is not long enough to show
some of these possibilities
i i wonder if another difference or i
wonder how relevant another difference
might be
that the power of
militaries and law enforcement today in
many countries
is very different in terms of both its
capacity to repress
certain types of of uh of uprising
um as well as its centralization
combined with the rapid spread of you
know you
the when the george floyd protests
started
they they almost started in tandem in
cities all across the country but they
were really discreetly
and separately organized protests thanks
to technology and communication methods
something that as you point out would
have been very different uh
some time ago what do you think about
that
as you know the power of military and
law enforcement in most western
democracies now
as something that would maybe prevent
circumstances from getting to a certain
point
um i think that the thing this is a
lesson from rome that i think is
important to understand
um in rome you had say in the fourth
century you had about 60 million people
and perhaps 500
000 soldiers and so it was a very
heavily militarized society
and the way that that society worked and
the way military was used to quell
dissent was
symbolic shows a force right you
couldn't actually police
this entire empire even with 500 000
troops and so what you would do
is you would basically um deploy troops
to
demonstrate that order and law uh
were still in place and that anarchy had
not kind of developed
and that uh there wasn't a kind of
separation from the empire in a
particular region
uh and i think that this is this is uh
still a feature of
modern western democracies right i mean
law enforcement
needs to um law enforcement does not
have the capacity to be everywhere at
all times
but i think that you're right that one
thing that is different now
is the the spread the rapid spread
of protests and reactions to stimuli
this is something that of course
couldn't happen in the roman empire
because if something happened in say
antioch
in syria no one in italy would know
about it for
two weeks uh and so you wouldn't have
had a spontaneous protest that happened
everywhere
immediately in response to something
because news wouldn't travel
fast enough and so i think there you do
have
a very significant difference that that
presents a real challenge
administratively
uh for a central government that the
romans never had to deal with
when people thinking now about 2020 when
people point to what they have observed
in the last four years of this
administration and then
make con draw conclusions from that
about the direction of democracy or
the state of of the united states is
four years even theoretically a long
enough period of time
to actually identify significant changes
in the state of democracy or or is it
simply too
short a period of time uh i think we can
see
really significant changes in the way
that we do things and talk about things
in this country in the last four years
okay the thing that's particularly
alarming to me is
uh the rise of violent rhetoric and then
the fact that we now have violence
spilling out into the streets
and in particular the way that the
rhetoric that's coming from the white
house
is matched by armed people going into
the streets to back up this way of
thinking
this is really different than anything
we've seen before in the united states
certainly in the last 50 years
uh and this is something that when this
emerged in rome
that was impossible for the republic to
control
there's a basic idea in any republic i
think but it's
articulated very well by romans that a
republic that is governed by law
can be it can endure forever in theory
but a republic that's governed by
violence is not a republic at all
because there's no consensus
between the people ruling and the people
being ruled that this is a lawful way of
behaving
and so violence once it emerges into
political
discussion and political debate is
something that
completely corrodes the lawful ability
for our society to make decisions
and so i think that is something that's
happened in the last four years that is
really profoundly dangerous and
really alarming what should we be paying
particular attention to over the next
for example
six weeks in terms of the election uh
three months in terms of the transition
period
and then the following four-year
presidential term that will come after
that
i think that if there's anything that we
need to be particularly vigilant in
controlling
uh it's getting violent out of our
political sphere
um people protesting with weapons is not
something that democracies should be
willing to tolerate
it's really really dangerous uh and the
other thing that that you see in the
roman period is when you
start with that very quickly you start
getting martyrs you know people
who are protesting with weapons may not
actually intend to hurt anybody it may
just be sort of a symbolic display of
the capacity
to be violent if necessary but protests
are heated
and when there's a political discussion
and people are armed sometimes there is
violence that no one intended
but as soon as you have martyrs it's
very very hard to walk
back from that and it's very very hard
to remove violence from a political
environment when you have people who
have died for a cause
and so this is you know especially as
we're looking at the next six weeks and
maybe the next few months
we need to walk back from that everybody
needs to walk back from that
because if you do have the eruption of
political violence in the context of
this election
it's going to be very very hard to
control that
and very very hard to get that out of
the way we make political decisions in
the future
yeah it's a bell that's difficult to
unring once uh
what once once you you've rung it um
we've been speaking with edward watts
who is both
professor of and chair of the history
department
at uc san diego the upcoming book is
rome's eternal decline
and fall due out next year uh really
great having you on and i so appreciate
your time
thank you this was great the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as
one dollar per month or as much as you
want
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
great perks and benefits as well read
about him
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
this is now becoming a pattern donald
trump very clearly does not want to take
questions from reporters right now
because the questions would
overwhelmingly be
about his tax returns about is paying no
income taxes
for 10 of the last 15 years about his
paying
750 dollars in federal income taxes in
the year he was elected and in his first
year as president his
exaggerations of the profitability of
his businesses and since donald trump
doesn't want to take the questions
he's just bailing out without taking
questions at public appearances
yesterday trump did
a total propaganda event at the white
house rose garden to talk about
again how great coronavirus testing
is going watching the event it seemed
like it was april all over again
trump talking about developing rapid
tests
he had the same people including his
admiral talk about how the rapid tests
work
mike pence spoke and spoke and thanked
uh trump for his great leadership on
coronavirus it was like going back in
time
six months as if the last six months
never even happened
but it was all a carefully crafted and
planned ruse
to create the appearance that donald
trump isn't hiding
but getting him off stage immediately
without answering any questions because
of course the questions would all be
about
the insane bombshell tax return
revelations that donald trump has worked
for years to keep secret here is donald
trump
wrapping up the event without taking a
single
question and very importantly vaccines
are coming but we're rounding the corner
regardless
but vaccines are coming and they're
coming fast we have four great companies
already and
uh it's going to be added to very
rapidly uh they're
in final stages of testing and from what
we're hearing the
results are going to be very
extraordinary so
thank you very much i appreciate it and
thank you very much great job by abbott
right from the beginning great job by
abbott
thank you thank you very much everybody
thank you bye-bye everybody just going
to walk back into the white house
without answering any of the dozens and
dozens of pressing questions about
the insane allegations about me and like
any good trump event trump
struggled to speak not recognizing the
word hospice on his script and calling
it haas
peace this is odd 10 million for home
health and
hospice care hospice care
agencies he just cannot get through
one of these without making a fool out
of himself here he is having a big
sort of dog and pony show having a
coronavirus
test done by the admiral for the cameras
to come up and demonstrate how these
tests are performed he'll do this very
nicely i think
good luck hope you don't test positive
funny guy right it's as if it's april
all over again and we don't know how to
test for coronavirus but we're figuring
it out and it's news
that we have tests now you'll remember
the day before
yesterday at trump's press briefing when
people
when reporters tried to ask donald trump
about the tax stuff
he did anything he could not to answer
here he just scolded a reporter for
asking about his taxes when he had
called on somebody else
for being a rude person tell us what you
paid in federal time
i'm talking to him you should be more
respectful of this gentleman be very
rude to him
but i will tell you that i look forward
to releasing
that i look forward to releasing many
things i'm going to release many things
and people will be really shocked
trump will release lots of things and
people will be shocked well i'm
convinced i'm not worried anymore
trump also called the new york times
story about his taxes fake news
and is still claiming that he just can't
release anything because he's under
audit
they are not releasing they're not
publishing the tax
terms they're not showing that out there
they're saying to protect their sources
in your tax return sir does that sound
right you're paying a couple hundred
dollars a year
income taxes fake news it's totally fake
news
made up fake we went through the same
stories you could have asked me the same
questions four years ago i had to
litigate this and talk about it
uh totally fake news now actually i paid
tax but and you'll see that as soon as
my tax returns are
it's underwater they've been underwater
for a long time
the irs does not treat me well they
treat me like the tea party like they
treated the tea party
they don't treat me well they treat me
very badly it's all
totally fake fake fake news eventually
trump is going to have to talk about
this right
i mean can trump i mean maybe he can you
tell me can trump
really avoid questions about this
through to the election on november 3rd
will chris wallace tonight in the first
debate
as the moderator will chris wallace
bring up the tax
situation if so i mean you have to
assume
trump is going to be prepared with
something in case taxes come up
whether people will buy it i i don't
know donald trump's
former personal lawyer michael cohen is
insisting
that the tax stuff is just the beginning
of this type of thing for donald trump
and uh note that
when michael cohen testified months ago
was exactly right michael cohen
testified months ago
or was it a year ago i don't even
remember when it was at this point time
has flown by
but michael cohen testified trump will
artificially either inflate or deflate
the value of his assets
depending on what he's trying to achieve
and it turns out that he was right
here's michael cohen reminding us of
that
so joy let me start with what i know and
to which i testified before the house
oversight committee
in february of 2019 what i stated was
that trump fraudulently
inflated the value of his properties in
order to receive
favorable terms from lenders only then
to under report their value
for tax purposes basically what i did is
i called him our liar in cheat
that everything he says is a conflation
of the truth
and i finalized by saying that the
valuation of donald trump's assets
is so disproportionate to their real
worth
that we have no idea the true evaluation
of anything that he owns
i mean it's guest lighting to the
extreme
trump has lied for so long about
literally
every facet of his life that the real
truth
is according to the new york times it's
it's shocking
yeah i started getting emails from
people
saying trump is going to pull out of
tonight's debate last minute
because it's just too risky given all of
this
tax stuff i still believe that the
debate
will happen i hope that you'll be there
with me if it does
i will be live on youtube twitch and
facebook
starting at 8 30 p.m eastern time 5 30
p.m
pacific don't miss it don't miss it we
want it to be
maybe it'll be the most successful
stream we've ever done but we will all
be together for it
and we will see if this topic of the
taxes comes up i hope that it will
uh we will see okay this is a risky
segment for me to do
why is it risky it's risky because it's
wonky
and it's technical and i don't know that
people will like it this might be the
type of segment that ends up with like
you know 5 000 views on youtube
but about 10 people have emailed me and
they've asked me to do this they've
requested this so let's do it we are
going to talk about
two mechanisms which donald trump and
other rich people can use
to reduce the amount they pay in taxes
the two mechanisms are
tax loss carry forwards please don't
glaze over
tax loss carry forwards and asset
depreciation okay so donald trump's
taxes were leaked by this blockbuster
new york times report
in that new york times report we learned
that there were some years like
2016 and 2017 when donald trump paid
750 in total federal taxes
total for the entire year in 10 of the
last
15 years donald trump paid zero
in federal taxes how on earth is this
possible well it's possible thanks to
something called
a tax loss carry forward and asset
depreciation i'm going to explain both
and you were very quickly going to see
how the tax code
favors the super rich as if you didn't
already know that
so what tax loss carry forward allows
you
to take a loss that happened in one year
and carry it forward
to future years to reduce the amount of
tax that you owe
so let's do like a very pedestrian
example compared to what donald trump is
doing
we'll do it with stocks imagine that you
buy twenty thousand dollars of some
stock
in one year and it loses fifty percent
of its value so your twenty thousand
dollars is now only ten thousand dollars
you lost ten thousand dollars great you
can deduct losses you can deduct
ten thousand dollars from your taxes
from the standpoint of paying
capital gains and it counts against your
gains beautiful
but imagine that in the year that you
lost the 10 grand and sold the stock and
realized that loss
you only made two thousand dollars from
all of your other stock sales
so you've got this ten thousand dollar
loss and only a two thousand dollar gain
well great news
you don't have to use the full ten
thousand dollar loss
in that year you had a two thousand
dollar gain
you'll take just two thousand dollars
from the ten that you lost
and you offset a two thousand dollar
gain with a two thousand dollar loss
you're at zero you pay no capital gains
and your other eight thousand dollars in
losses
can be carried over to future
years now maybe the next year you have a
really good year in stocks
and you realize seven thousand dollars
in gains well
you still have the eight thousand
dollars in loss
that you carried over you can use
another seven
thousand to offset the money you made in
stocks
and again you pay zero now
that sounds reasonable enough and it's
simple enough but that is small potatoes
that's not how trump takes advantage of
it
real losses on the sale of stock
are not what donald trump is doing
donald trump is generating paper losses
with capital losses from huge hotels and
casinos so
here's an example in 1995
donald trump reported a loss of 916
million dollars on a casino
and we'll talk about how that loss was
generated
he then gets to take that 960 million
dollar loss and
offset 50 million dollars in taxes per
year
for 18 years in 2008
and 2009 donald trump declared a loss
of 1.4 billion dollars and he
extended the ability to carry these
losses forward indefinitely
in his own tax plan which was made
effective in 2018.
so trump can take that 1.4 billion
dollar loss
and just carry it forward indefinitely
offsetting future taxes
and the trick of it is that you can also
mess with how you declare these losses
so
we imagine listen i buy something for a
thousand
bucks and i sell it for 500. i really
lost
500 that's a real loss of 500
with these huge real estate transactions
and capital investments there are all
sorts of ways
that you can move around assets and mess
with the valuation of the assets i'll
get
back to that later to generate losses on
paper
which didn't really happen in the way
you or i think about
losing money and you're generating these
paper losses which you can then carry
forward your average middle class
working person can't do this
now the other tactic donald trump uses
where do you generate these losses to
carry forward
one of the ways you can do it is with
asset depreciation depreciation means
the value of an asset has gone down if i
have a car that's worth
you know fifteen thousand dollars when i
buy it and after a couple of years it's
worth ten thousand dollars
that's depreciated by five thousand
dollars now with a huge real estate
portfolio
you know a hotel a casino a big office
building
you don't just buy it and deduct it as a
business expense
like i would do with like an audio cable
or you know i bought this new microphone
this year
i'm not going to depreciate this
microphone over the next however many
years it's too small of an expense
i'm just going to take it as a business
expense and deduct it right away
but with a huge hotel if you claim to
have a hotel worth 500 million dollars
and then now you claim you know the
hotel has aged the plumbing is older you
know you've got to flush the toilets 10
to 15 times as trump says
you could say the hotel was worth 500
million
it's now worth 250 million i can now
take 250 million dollars in depreciation
and reduce my taxes and this is where
the manipulations come into play
michael cohen has explained to us how
trump does this without actually
changing anything in the real world
if i can claim you know my 500 million
dollar hotel
it's really worth 600 million so what
that means is when it goes down in value
to 250 i'm not depreciating 250 million
i can now depreciate 350 million dollars
and create a loss carry forward that i
can use for the next however many years
it's all imaginary it's all merely
pushing paper
it's accounting mechanisms and we know
trump did this
the taxes prove it and michael cohen and
others have told us
donald trump for publicity purposes
or for tax purposes or for whatever
reason to get a loan
trump will inflate asset values when
it's convenient
or deflate asset values when it's
convenient these are the mechanisms
trump has used
this is how they work hopefully it's
useful to folks to understand it
we have a voicemail number which is 2192
davidp
uh this is a voicemail that relates to
media literacy
unfortunately i'm worried i'm worried
this is one of those voicemails that
attacks me
for things that i don't actually claim
to be
take a listen uh hey david
i'm really upset um
honestly you and your coverage of
you know just the news oh no especially
in the lab i mean i've never really been
a um fan of your method i think that you
have this sort of mainstream media um
manufacturing consent sort of technique
where you pretend
like you you're not biased or that bias
is
wrong or that you're somehow like
objective and just calling balls and
strikes when you're clearly injecting
your opinion
okay so this goes on for three minutes
but guys come how many times we
we need media literacy you know we hear
fox news viewers can't distinguish
between news and opinion programming and
fox uses it to their advantage
i have always been unequivocally
unapologetically clear this is an
opinion show this
is a left wing show i do my best to be
objective with the facts and then i give
you my opinion which is a left wing
opinion
so criticize me for something real but
criticizing me for pretending that this
is not a left-wing opinion program come
on guys
come on we're in trouble if this is what
we're dealing with
we've got a great bonus show for you
today and we have a live debate stream
tonight joe biden versus donald trump
join me at 8 30 pm eastern time i'll see
you there
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to com blinkist.com david
pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video